the Joe Rogan experience it'll be cool
if they had like a card with all
different types of fighting on that's
what one does mm-hmm you know all in the
same night yes one Fc does that they'll
have kickboxing Muay Thai and MMA in one
night is it no no no they let everybody
know no this is what they're doing I
think one is doing fantastic they're
doing they're they're putting on amazing
fights I mean and we've seen that these
are like legitimately world-class
fighters they're beating guys like they
you know Timothy nuts you can just beat
Eddie Alvarez yeah and they're also they
cut out all the weight cutting there's
no weight cutting over there
so like when sage Northcutt fought Cosmo
Aleksandra he fought him in 185 pounds
cuz that's really what he walks around
you know so there's no weight cutting
over there that was a brutal hit crazy
I'm glad that he's okay yeah he's okay
but yeah his faces had eight fractures
do you think it's better for him to cut
down that's a good question because very
good question because I mean if he's
getting knocked out by that I'm
wondering if maybe he should be walking
around lighter or I don't know he's
pretty lean already he's lean but that's
that fight played out realistically like
not not that it's better for him or
worse for him but sage is a young guy
he's 21 or 22 years old he's got a
limited amount of world-class Muay Thai
experience
he fought Cosmo who was a multiple time
world champion yeah and it's just a bad
fight why why did they why would they
set that up if they're trying to build
him it's easy like I've said that too
and people like oh it's easy to say
after the fact you're right but if I was
in Sage's corner hey bro there's a lot
of fights we should take and that was a
muy Thai fight no it was an MMA fight
okay but sage is not a wrestler yeah I
mean has taken guys down before but I
would absolutely say that's the game
plan the game plan is tie this guy up
and drag him to the ground don't don't
be standing with this - I just feel like
if you if you have a background in
something in in stressful situations you
always revert back to what you know sure
yeah so even if he did work as wrestling
he's gonna revert back to his
you know really hoppy movie dancin and
that that's that's what it looked like
what happened he was kind of pulling out
hopping back hot yeah well he was trying
that sideways karate style stance and
you know Cosmo is just super elite and
he saw if you saw the fight he fainted a
couple times with the left he set him up
like with a switch a couple times and
then as sage circled off he went to his
right and cracked him but that guy is
just a super elite fighter I mean when
it comes to striking I feel like that is
where being elite is the most dangerous
for an opponent you know I feel like if
someone if you fight an elite jiu-jitsu
guy and he catches you and he submits
you you live another day
you know like Neil Magny and Demian Maia
we found out you know Damian gets them
to the ground and just strangles him
right yeah but that's he'll be alright
if you get Kayode by an elite striker
who knows what kind of damage happens to
you you know when his face got broken
he's had eight fractures in his face his
cheek is orbital like they had a piece
him back together it was attached do you
know I don't know I don't know the
extent of the injuries he posted up some
images though did you see the images of
the x-rays whoa this is is horrible
[Applause]